bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
beaucoup de cultures dépend des abeilles
domestiques pour fournir un bon
rendement
on n'a qu'à penser aux bleuets ou aux
canneberges mais ces insectes
pollinisateurs ne sont pas originaires
d'ici l'hiver signe donc souvent leur
arrêt de mort pour donner un coup de
pouce aux reines et permettre de
reconstruire les colonies plus
rapidement au printemps des
scientifiques ont trouvé un moyen
original de les abriter pendant la
saison froide
[Musique]
parce que si on est vraiment dans nord
ont frôlé 49e parallèle facon une région
qui est mort hier les producteurs qui
sont plus au sud 42 sorties des rennes à
partir de début juin nous on n'est pas
capable donc on peut juste sorti des
reines fécondées à partir de la saint
jean
donc tu sais la troisième de joueurs
fait qu'on perd quand même deux semaines
gabriel boucher guimond et apiculteur à
desbiens au lac saint jean depuis six
ans il se spécialise dans l'élevage de
reines des reines destinée à bâtir des
ruches qui serviront à la production de
miel ou à la pollinisation
le problème c'est que l'hiver environ
25% des abeilles meurent ces pertes
hivernales ralentissent le processus de
production des ruches
résultat chaque printemps ses clients
apiculteurs n'ont d'autre choix que
d'importer des reines de l'étranger
s'ils veulent avoir des ruches à temps
pour la pollinisation entre les mois de
mars et mai plus de 200000 rennes
arrivent par avion chaque année au
canada
elles viennent de régions chaudes comme
la californie à wailly le chili et
l'australie
gabriel voudrait bien produire des
reines locale plus tôt en saison
c'est pourquoi il collabore avec andré
rousseau une chercheuse en apiculture au
centre de recherche en sciences animales
de deschamps de ce qu'on sait faire on
sent bien voir si on ne dérape en deux
donc ce qu'on fait c'est que on vient
ouvrir notre richesse de fécondation il
ya quatre petites unités
à l'intérieur quatre petites populations
dans lesquels on le place et une cellule
royal andré et son équipe ont trouvé une
solution pour diminuer l'importation de
rennes elles ont créé des colonies
d'abeilles inusité pour avoir des reines
local dès le printemps
elles font ce qu'on appelle du banc cage
de rennes le projet vise à hiverner une
très très grande quantité de rennes dans
une seule colonie puis être capable de
faire survivre c'est rennes le pendant
l'hiver habituellement il ya une seule
reine pond buzz dans la colonie c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne si à
plusieurs reines en fait elles vont se
battre ensemble qui essayait de 2000 et
pourrait être la seule reine pondeuses
la colonie
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on en class 40 et
puis toutes les abeilles de la colonie
vont être chargés d'alimenter ses 40
règne qui peuvent pas toucher parce
qu'ils sont en cage est individuel les
abeilles qui sont autour des on appelle
ça la cour royale ont toujours s'occuper
de la nourrir l'aller chez lui donner
des soins pour s'assurer qu'il puisse
faire son travail de ponte
pendant l'hiver la reine 16 de pondre et
la colonie entière est mise à rude
épreuve pour les aider à survivre les
apiculteurs ont deux façons conserver
leurs colonies soit il les laisse dehors
avec un isolant autour de la ruche soit
ils les installe à l'intérieur d'une
cabane ou d'un caveau à une température
d'environ 4 degrés celsius
les abeilles sont peu son plan de
relance a fait devons réduire leur
métabolisme consommer minimalement se
réchauffer entre elles en formant une
grappes d'abeilles puis vont survivre
tout l'hiver comme ça sept groupes se
forment autour de l'arène pour conserver
sa chaleur et assurer sa survie
mais pour optimiser la survie de 40
rennes banques et dans une seule colonie
les scientifiques y neuf en testant
différentes températures
nous ce qu'on voulait voir c est ce que
en augmente à la température la grappe
veut se dissiper un peu puis on va avoir
un meilleur maintien des rangs d'une
meilleure survie des rennes parce que
les rênes sont placés dans un cadre qui
vont prendre beaucoup d espace donc on
veut maximiser la survie puis invité la
grappe d'abeilles dès la première année
les scientifiques ont banque s y sont
reines et les résultats ont dépassé
leurs attentes
c'était une très très grande surprise de
découvrir 85% de survie de nos reines à
15 degrés celsius tout le monde nous
disait qu'on est un peu fou de tester
cette température là parce que les
abeilles aller s'affoler et y aller
consommer aussi beaucoup de ressources
on s'est dit on les sait on le tente on
est des chercheurs si nous on ne le fait
pas personne ne veut le faire puis ça a
payé de prendre ce risque là
[Musique]
l'été touche à sa fin et c'est rennes
ont conduit leur dernier de la saison
l'heure est venue de regrouper les rênes
dans une seule et même colonie audrey
venu me rejoindre pour justement monter
les banques car elles ont trait aussi la
méthode de travail qu'il faut voir le
banquet de rennes se fait en deux étapes
il faut d'abord enlever les rênes de
chacune des colonies puis les placer
dans des petites cages individuelles à
l'abri de la lumière
une fois le calme revenu
on place car entraîne par ruche les
abeilles en prendront soin tout l'hiver
dans la carte spéciale jusqu'à 20 ou ce
qu'on est capable de mettre 20 rennes de
bord d'une façade score qui va y règne
sur l'autre
donc ensuite on va venir pas qui sort
[Musique]
mais avant de distribuer les rênes aux
apiculteurs de partout au pays
il faut s'assurer que cette nouvelle
technique d'hivernage n'affecte pas la
qualité des reines et au centre de
recherche de deschambault cette mission
est entre les mains de mireille lévesque
[Musique]
en fait la qualité des rennes caen va
mesurer après l'hiver va être comparé à
des colonies témoins sont des colonies
dans laquelle la reine a été laissé
libre
la reine est fécondé une seule fois dans
sa vie lors d'un vol avec des bourdons
tout autour d'elle puis elle concerne le
sperme dans une spermathèque pour pondre
tout au long du printemps et de l'été
pour s'assurer que la fertilité de la
reine n'est pas affectée par le blocage
en plus du nombre d'eux il va falloir
regarder la reine de plus près on va
aller récolter la spermathèque quittant
le dernier segment dans le domaine et on
va mélanger le contenu de la
spermathèque avec des colorants qui vont
colorer les spermatozoïdes vivant en
verre et les spermatozoïdes mais en
rouge
donc ça va nous donner une idée du
pourcentage de viabilité des
spermatozoïdes
bonne nouvelle mireille a découvert que
les spermatozoïdes sont encore vivants
après le bandage le printemps prochain
l'équipe de recherche étudiera cette
fois la performance de la colonie en
pesant les ruches pour évaluer la
production de miel mais déjà gabriele
d'optimistes ce serait son deuxième
hiver de banques âge il a amélioré sa
technique et il est certain d'augmenter
le taux de survie de ces reines
cette année il a d'ailleurs décidé de
tout les banquets
[Musique]
on aimerait ça au moins un nivernais
1000 par année
c'est sûr que économiquement c'est
vraiment rentable parce que même si au
caveau même sur les frais d'électricité
on maximise l'espace du caveau puis on
va rentabiliser sa coupe donné ça va
être rentabilisé pour le cheptel
québécois on est capable de garder notre
génétique qui est plus rustique n'ont
pas besoin d'amener des reines de
partout puisqu'elles savent pas trop
quoi faire avec steve r
l'hiver est aux portes du lac saint jean
et gabrielle doit attendre la tombée de
la nuit pour déplacer ces ruches de
cette façon ils s'assurent que les
abeilles sont toutes rentrées à
l'intérieur après leur journée de
butinage les jeux vont vraiment ici ils
vont passer l'hiver
donc on a vraiment un contrôle sur la
température regarder sa caisse aux
prétentions des chaleurs on s'attendait
pas à un asthmatique il faut tout
régulière ce qui est souhaitable c'est
davantage de choix pour les apiculteurs
on veut toujours être dépendant de la
bei d'ailleurs mais si on peut donner
d'autre choix aux apiculteurs en termes
de rennes en termes de sélection puis
encourager l'élevage le calebasse avait
déjà être plus c'est sûr qu'on pense pas
fournir le québec en entier dès demain
avec notre projet mais c'est un peu
voire plus de choix puis une habitude
pour qui un peu plus durable
rendez vous au printemps prochain avec
des rennes locales qui auront peut-être
eu l'impression de passer l'hiver dans
le sud
[Musique]
on l'a vu installer les rênes dans des
petits dortoirs bien au chaud c'est une
façon de les aider à survivre à l'hiver
mais il y a plus d apiculteurs et des
scientifiques sélectionne génétiquement
leur haine pour qu'elle résiste à la
saison froide
[Musique]
le but principal plus travailler sur la
sélection de la bei ces de l'adapter au
contexte canadien québécois on suit des
familles d'abeilles sur plusieurs
générations et c'est vraiment le fait de
pouvoir connaître les maires les
grands-mères les filles et de suivre
toutes ces familles de suivre leurs
performances qui m'a intéressé
passionnés
[Musique]
pour élever drm et des abeilles adaptées
aux climats nordiques
rien n'est laissé au hasard la
doctorante ségolène maucourt et la
chercheuse
andré rousseau du centre de recherche en
sciences animales de deschambault
sélectionne les meilleurs colonies
d'abeilles pour les faire se reproduire
une reine de bonne qualité c'est une
rampe qui va avoir été bien féconde et
elle doit être très fertile donc on veut
une rente qui équipent prolifique puis
qui va nous donner des caractères
génétiques que désirable donc c'est elle
qui est porteuse de toutes la génétique
de la colonie c'est important qu'elle
ait des caractères souhaité par
l'apiculteur pour perpétuer la génétique
idéal andré rosso procède à une
opération d'insémination la simulation
ce que ça nous permet de faire c'est
d'aller sélectionner des faux bourdons
d'une seule colonie puis d'inséminer une
reine avec le sperme de ces faux
bourdons le pour vraiment obtenir une
reine qui vaut vraiment dont on veut
connaître totalement les géniteurs
le faux bourdon est le géniteur de
l'abbaye ils sont des dizaines à
inséminer une reine lors de son vol de
fécondation qui n'a lieu qu'une seule
fois dans sa vie on va prendre la reine
vierge puis on va vraiment essayer de
simuler le plus possible qui se passe en
atout
andré rousseau est une des rares
personnes dans le monde à savoir faire
une insémination de rennes
cette opération requiert une grande
dextérité la reine est endormie elle est
placée dans un tube dans un angle bien
précis puis elle son orifice vaginal qui
est sorti à l'extérieur qui nous ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on va vraiment aller
porter le sperme à l'intérieur de son
orifice vaginale puis le sperme vont
migrer jusqu'à son organe notre posage
la spermathèque après l'opération la
reine féconde sera introduite dans une
colonie orpheline pour pondre les
précieuses larves au pic de la saison
la reine pond jusqu'à 2000 par jour on
différencie la reine des ouvrières par
son abdomen qui est plus long et plus
large et par son thorax qui est un peu
plus gros et bombay qu'on appelle la
couronne
[Musique]
avec un set puis d'autres producteurs ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on leur envoie ses
rennes pour qu'ils soient testés dans
leur environnement
ici à ferme-neuve dans les hautes
laurentides ça fait longtemps que cannes
et sète desrochers a opté pour la
sélection génétique il est le plus gros
éleveurs de rennes au canada il produit
environ 1200 rennes par semaine ce qui
fait un total de douze à quinze mille
rennes par saison d'éleveurs de rennes
c'est l'apiculteur qui est un peu sur le
front des reconstructions des
populations d'abeilles qui décline
dernières années
annuellement on part entre 30 et 50 % de
la population mondiale d'abeilles pour
rebâtir les cheptels année après année
c'est important de le faire et c'est
important de faire avec une avait aussi
qu'ils vont devenir
idéalement tolérante résistante rustique
adapté à son territoire pour mieux
lutter contre ces prêts sont là pour
donner ce coup de pouce à l'adaptation
des abeilles domestiques
on s'en va dans les 150 ruches et de
sélection du centre de recherche des
chambres les rênes et leurs ouvrières
sont sélectionnés sur des critères bien
précis comme la rusticité la santé ou
encore la production de miel ou
pour évaluer la santé d'une colonie
ségolène et son équipe réalisent un test
d'hygiène avoir une colonie qui a une
capacité de nettoyage assez forte
ça va lui permettre de mieux lutter
contre
les parasites les maladies etc parce que
la malade y aura pas le temps de
s'installer
vraiment dans la rue je les avais vont
pouvoir la gérer rapidement puis
nettoyées pour éviter que ça se propage
donc là j'ai du couvain du constat tu
veux venir placer mes petits cylindres
le coin d'abeilles c'est les larves
d'abeilles en fait de futurs abeilles on
met de l'azoté liquide dans le cylindre
ce qui va venir refroidir le couvain et
le tuer
et 24 heures après on revient voir la
colonie dans cette zone là et on va
regarder à quel point les abeilles ont
été en capacité de nettoyer ce pouvoir
donc on peut voir les deux cercles qui
se trouvait ici on voit que le couvain
été nettoyées complètement que les
cellules sont entièrement vide
donc ça c'est une colonie ici qui est
100% hygiénique
les scientifiques évaluent aussi la
capacité de défense de la colonie envers
un prédateur ou l'apiculteur une place
un petit patch de cuir convient balancé
à l'aide d'une canne à pêche au dessus
de la colonie qui est ouvert et on va
venir regarder si les abeilles ont
tendance à venir attaquer ce patch ou à
l'ignorer complètement pouvoir qu'on a
pas beaucoup de réactions des abeilles
pour le moment on cherche à avoir une
abeille qui soit pas trop douce mais pas
trop agressive non plus soit quand même
en fait capable de se défendre face à
des prédateurs ça peut être des
mouffettes des ours etc
il faut quand même qu'ils gardent cet
instinct
important de survie 6 7 8 9 10 ségolène
maucourt combine ensuite les résultats
de tous ces tests et elle fait des
calculs pour choisir quelle reine elle
va reproduire ces de la sélection à base
de génétique quantitative
c'est un domaine de la génétique qui se
base sur des analyses statistiques qui
va permettre de lier à la fois la
performance de la colonie avec la
généalogie des colonies
la compilation de toutes ces données
permet de noter chacune des colonies
celles qui auront la meilleure note
seront conservés pour la reproduction et
pour avoir un modèle statistique encore
plus robuste
la jeune chercheuse a décidé de
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait en
agriculture on se base sur un modèle
statistique qui est un modèle à la base
qui étaient utilisés pour les ports les
vaches depuis une trentaine d'années
pour donner un exemple assez
assez spectaculaire chez le porc en dix
ans avec ce système de sélection on a pu
augmenter le nombre de porcelets par
truie de trois ports ce lait
supplémentaire nous on veut se servir de
ce modèle là pour améliorer les
caractères chez la bei au niveau de la
production de miel de développement
printanier du comportement et génique et
cetera pour que la bei soit plus adapté
au contexte nordiques du québec
seren sélectionnés seront ensuite
reproduites par insémination et le cycle
de reproduction recommence les rênes
pont depuis andré et ségolène récupère
les larves pour produire de nouvelles
générations d'abeilles et de faubourg
d'eau on va partir avec ce corner
l'excellent bleus pour aller commencé
l'élevage royal
oui je vais choisir un mail avec soin
dans le cadre il y en eut ce père festif
à la fin je transporte doucement les
larmes du beau linge avec la gelée
royale dans mes cuculles ensuite mort
les transférer dans une colonie éleveuse
de cellules royales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fois transféré les larves seront
nourris avec de la gelée royale par les
abeilles nourricière et elles
deviendront rennes à leur tour ça dure
environ cinq jours pour produire une
reine de l'oeuf à la reine vierge qui va
naître ce cycle de vie anicet desrochers
le connais par coeur son rythme de
production en dépend on prélève la reine
qui est féconde qui est mature et puis
en les heures qui vont suivre y
introduire un nouvel rennes émergentes
comme dans le 24 à 36 heures suivant un
cycle continu du mois de mai jusqu'au
mode s'y attendre
propager la génétique de ces reines les
scientifiques se sont tournés vers des
éleveurs comme anicet desrochers à qui
ils ont envoyé leurs meilleurs spécimens
les éleveurs vont ensuite les multiplier
en plus de leur propre reine et les
apiculteurs de partout au pays vont
pouvoir en bénéficier
donc j'ai des stades d'abeilles qui vont
partir de ferme-neuve jusque sur
vancouver sur l'alberta sur l'ontario
sur les maritimes aux apiculteurs qui
traînent décision d'avoir un abbé
locales et toute une logistique le plus
vite possible
on est capable d'engendrer cette
logistique d'acheminement vers
l'apiculteur de mieux savoir être la
qualité la longévité qui au final la
survie des populations avec ça va
engendrer
c'est ainsi que l'abeille domestique
originaires d'europe a été sélectionné
pour être adaptées au climat d'ici
aujourd'hui on la retrouve partout sur
le continent nord américain
en couplant la sélection génétique avec
le banc cage les apiculteurs devrait
avoir plus d'options pour acheter une
reine locale juste à temps pour la
pollinisation
mon souhait c'est vraiment continuer sur
cette voie là donc de maximiser la
production la qualité des reines pour
avoir une agriculture qui équipent
durables puis qui est fonctionnel
à l'échelle québécoise
[Musique]